the speed of sound is approximately 768
miles per hour when an object travels
faster than the speed of sound it
creates a sonic boom and there's
actually a whole video on how sonic
booms are created on Khan Academy I
encourage you to watch it it's actually
fascinating but anyway back to this
question write an inequality to
represent s the speeds at which a moving
object creates a sonic boom so what has
to let's write an inequality let's
suppose to do what they told us to s LCS
has to be they say when an object
travels faster than the speed of sound
so our speed has to be greater than the
speed of sound our speed has to be
greater than the speed of sound which is
768 miles per hour so s has to be set
greater than 768 now another way we
could have written that is that 768
needs to be less than s we could have
written 768 needs to be less than s
that's another way we could write it in
either case our speed is going to be
greater than 768 miles per hour we check
our answer let's do a few more of these
to cook a steak to medium-rare it needs
to have an internal temperature of 135
degrees Fahrenheit a lower internal
temperature will under cook the steak
write an inequality to represent all of
the possible temperatures T of an
undercooked steak well to be an
undercooked steak your temperature is
going to be less than 135 degrees so
your temperature T is going to be less
in you could either just use the left
hand less than on your keyboard or you
could click over here on less than your
temperature is going to be less than 135
we're assuming your temperatures in
Fahrenheit degrees so your temperatures
but needs to be less than Fahrenheit
less than 135 degrees if you are going
to have an N undercooked steak so we've
got that one right let's do let's do a
couple more or well let's do one more
Simone is going snowboarding is going
snowboarding tomorrow if the temperature
is equal to or colder than five degrees
Celsius write an inequality to represent
the temperatures at which Simone will go
snowboarding so you might want to say
you might want to say oh well maybe you
know T is less than five degrees
remember they're telling us that the
temperature is equal to or colder so
she's even willing to go snowboarding if
it's less than or equal to five degrees
so instead of just saying less than
let's say less than or eat whoops let's
say less than let's say less than or
equal to five degrees so this inequality
represented here this shows us all of
the temperatures ne all of the
temperatures at which she is willing to
go norm no snowboarding and check our
answer and we got it right